[Music]
britney spears just went digging through
the vault and is bringing back one of
her oldies yeah it's cool on wednesday
britt posted this clip dancing around to
her 2003 track brave new girl off her in
the zone album in two different outfits
[Music]
the 39 year old posted a lengthy caption
alongside the video explaining in part
quote i've been holding on to this for a
while because it's one of the first
times i've shared my music i was
researching on my computer and was
checking out some of my songs that
haven't been released as singles and
holy smokes there's a lot brit says she
came across this song and thought it was
quote kinda cool before admitting she
forgot the lyrics to the end of the song
[Music]
and brittany says the self-directed
homemade video is just a little insight
into what you can do quote you know a
home studio with no lights and a
four-year-old phone i made this video in
two hours edited all of it i know some
videos can be made in a day or two
[Music]
britt also seemed to allude to her
journey to freedom following the news
that her dad jamie spears had been
suspended from her conservatorship quote
i feel like i have been a caged animal
for half of my life that's exactly why i
chose to direct myself do my makeup
myself produce myself dress myself make
music myself feed myself and shoot
videos and picks myself
i'm so pleased and proud to say
jamie spears
is no longer a conservator in a separate
post on instagram the lucky singer
thanked her attorney matthew rosengart
for working towards freeing her from the
conservatorship she's been under for the
last 13 years she added quote i suggest
if you have a friend that's been in a
house that feels really small for four
months no car no phone no door for
privacy and they have to work around 10
hours a day seven days a week and give
tons of blood weekly with never a day
off i strongly suggest you go pick up
your friend and get them the hell out of
there where do you see brittany's life
going from here as she talked about what
she might want to do when this is over
in a month hopefully she's got a great
future ahead of her
[Music]
you